as we make way for Rich Eisen who had a
great seat last night's festivities and
the Yankee fan joins us on the program
rich how you feeling
our ADP is a heck of a game last night I
was unbelievable where where were your
seats buddy of mine has had season
tickets right behind home plate just
literally a stone's throw away from Mary
Hart got the got the text right around
Friday night last week middle of Game
six of the ALCS you want to go to a Game
two of the World Series I just texted
back I'll be more than happy to help you
root against the Astros if you want em
big Dodger fan because I was feeling
that and the pit in my stomach that the
Yankees just weren't gonna pull it off
somehow someway it just felt that way
and but seeing the Astros last night
that was unbelievable I mean that that
that that homerun barrage against a
bullpen that had been previously on
touched by anybody pretty much in the
plows had that record set of straight
zeros that they were hanging up that was
unbelievable and then how the Dodgers
came back the place was just nuts I
really have not seen anything like that
but that was that was really incredible
and the Astros proved that this can be
seven-game or I think what did it sound
like with those last two home runs by
the Astros it was dead silent I mean
absolutely dead silent you know you
could hear the sound of Korea's bat
landing really throwing it so I never
I've never seen anything that thrown
that high in the air and you could hear
a pin drop and then but the fact he
could say although the the Marwin
Gonzalez homerun was the the biggest
shocker because it came on off of Jansen
who I think everybody in that building
thought was completely untouched uh your
your sense of this is Dan I hate the six
out save from your closer I think that
is very risky
when you don't have to be because it
puts you in the position of that's your
last move you have to lead in the eighth
inning why would you make your last best
move and I understand that they did have
Altuve up in Korea up in the 8th and
that's when it's time you bring in your
closer maybe but I'm what's your
philosophy on that six out save I get
the feeling the six out save is like
prevent defense in the NFL yeah because
I and baseball players are you know
they're so tied to their rituals and
it's a pattern and this is what I do and
when I do it and how I do it at what
time of the game I do it now all of a
sudden you start to change that and I
know it's it's not looking back and
saying you know hey they made the wrong
move by bringing him in he could have
had the two out there two inning save
and we would have moved on not said a
thing about it
I'd like guys being in their rhythm in
their routine and keeping it that way
and Janssen is the best closer but I
like him as the best closer when he's
got to get three outs give credit to the
others dad you know they got they put
the battle on the ball and when they do
they make things happen there they were
the best offense in baseball and you
finally saw that last night in dramatic
fashion yeah and then they're just so
young and good with Springer Correa and
Altuve all going yard like that but the
Dodgers are really deep and really good
with a lot of guys that are coming to
the floor right now it was just great to
see it was really just incredible to
certain certainly since you were good it
looked like you were seeing a repeat of
the night before same exact score same
situation where we're solo home runs for
exchange then a 2-run shot provided the
difference and then all holy heck broke
loose I've never seen anything like it
most famous person sitting around you
was well I guess Oscar De La Hoya was
right around to the left beyond that
with Sandy Koufax sitting right in front
of Magic Johnson that was that was
pretty neat to see like Los Angeles
sports icons
I think magic left to go to see
Lonzo versus John Wall towards the an I
don't think he stuck for the whole thing
but I know you've got Larry King on
tomorrow on I'm sure you saw that too he
didn't budge
he still of the whole thing yeah I love
that whole thing and he eats he eats the
whole game the problem of those seats at
least in season when I was in or
off-camera most of the time I guess I
strayed in towards the end but that's
gotta be tough you got to be careful
that whole time that you're on watching
the game I wouldn't want that
he's Rich Eisen NFL Network host host of
the Rich Eisen show tonight it's the
Ravens and the Dolphins I want to talk
to you about Cam Newton's prints
conference yesterday and two days if we
could play the final exchange between
Cam and the media from yesterday and
then we'll get Rich's take on that big
plays big chunk plays kind of good to
get to that energy I think that you're
talking about does this offense I know
you have had several Detroit New England
you think you guys have the wherewithal
to do that up consistent or even a
weekend
where do we stand on things here rich
well I just think that we're all waiting
for cam to stand there like he's the CEO
of the Carolina Panthers and answer all
questions regardless of whether he feels
they have value or not that that
question right there was a yes or no
question where I mean what do you want
their answer no I don't think we're good
I don't think we're gonna be consistent
enough to have big chunk plays why would
you ask the quarterback now there there
is some legitimacy within the question
which is that they do have they do have
an issue being a consistent offensive
team now how you posed the question to a
quarterback of that team is you've got
to be big I guess in a manner make sure
that you get the answer you're eliciting
but so in that and that specific
question I mean what do you want them to
say now but if we're waiting for him to
be the CEO answering all questions
guard less of them and I don't think
we're ever going to see that from cam we
saw in the beginning of his career where
Steve Smith had to talk to him about his
body language on the sidelines and at
the podium
we saw it after the Super Bowl we've
seen it now twice this year once where
he made a mess of the situation himself
and now another where at the end of nine
minutes he he he walks off and you're
not gonna see the team criticize him
from a public relations standpoint
they're gonna back his play I mean
because he's cam and they you know he's
the leader of the team so as long as we
just expect that we're not gonna get
what we we assume is a CEO type
performance from him at the podium I
think he is who he is to use the the NFL
phrase yeah it's different in what we
expect from a quarterback a coach Bill
Parcells or Bill Belichick they could
get up there and whatever they said or
didn't say
Gregg Popovich with a quarterback it's
different because I feel like a
quarterback has a brand that they're
always selling something and cam does
endorsements Brady's doing endorsement
breeze Rodgers they're all up there
Russell Wilson you have an opportunity
to use it and granted there are
questions you're not gonna like but part
of that is you've gotta fend that off
and move on in its 10 12 15 minutes of
your week get through it slug through it
and then move on but when you're gonna
roll your eyes now now the media can't
wait for the next time around so if you
didn't like this now they're coming back
yeah I the issue is I guess Dan and with
him in particular is that we watch him
celebrate his touchdowns you know and
then two years ago is obviously when
that was the apex of all of that so in
the media now if he can't take the
moments if whether there's heat or not
and the times when they're not
succeeding then you know you get caught
in that
Riptide of okay so we cover you when
you're excited but you don't like it
when we cover you when you're not and
that's a tough place to be when you're
an athlete let alone a high-profile one
like Cam and so look I think you just
have to come
unfortunately to expect it I if I'm
running a team I prefer not to have that
issue at the podium with my quarterback
but I don't know how they're handling it
or if it needs to be handled a woman
would be the one to do it quite frankly
you got the game tonight I feel like
this is spotlight on Joe Flacco like
where of you gonzo Flacco we're not
asking that question anymore is Joe
Flacco an elite quarterback Matt Moore I
like I liked him more than I did Jay
Cutler I wouldn't have gone out to get
Cutler in the first place but this feels
like it's a Flacco moment tonight good
or bad your thoughts on tonight's
matchup you know I obviously things do
always fall on a quarterback but I mean
you just take a look at the rosters in
terms of the offense and in terms of the
play calling you and and it's just not
even it's not even close I mean the
Dolphins are so far in a way better at
the skilled positions then the Ravens
where you know you're they're still
waiting for Macklin to stay healthy long
enough to see what he can do then the
same with Perriman the running backs
group Danny Woodhead going down early in
the season obviously didn't help but
when you look around the rest of the
league and looking at dynamic offenses
and who has them the Dolphins are one of
them for sure and the Ravens just aren't
so I don't know how you're gonna be
point four point with anybody regardless
of who the quarterback is based on who's
who the Ravens are putting out on the
field offensive ly quite frankly and you
know Flacco did look really good
in Oakland a couple of weeks ago other
than that we really haven't seen much of
a flash of anything they did start to a
know but other than that I think this is
clearly the Steelers division yeah and
and we'll see how the Dolphins can throw
their hat in the ring with the Patriots
and and the bills who can't be
discounted that Bills Raiders game is a
big week eight as well so I don't know
if it's as much Flacco as it is who
they're putting out there for Flacco to
throw to these Rich Eisen NFL Network
host tonight dolphins and the Ravens and
of course host of the Rich Eisen show
and did your producer catch a foul ball
last night
executive RTO executives as he likes to
be called my cell to pho did in fact
catch one and then got a selfie with him
and the foul ball with Peyton Manning I
mean is it that might be the greatest
performance of Game two
to be honest with you Dan I know what we
saw on the field last night but catching
a foul ball and having a selfie with
Peyton that's a that's a good one yes
bowling branch a question from the day
Nets if you were behind home plate and
you knew you're on camera and you caught
a foul ball would you look to give it to
the nearest kid of course nice come on
Paul Paul Paul that's sort of like the
question like I almost I rolled because
I think a lot of people would not was
catching a foul ball is a really big
moment for people you're a smart guy you
know perceptions big in a situation like
that I would know I'm on camera I would
let the little boy look at it and then
after the cameras off I would grab it I
would just say here look at the eye you
never know in the eye and the sky's
looking at you you never know but while
we're doing housekeeping I know you're
probably up against a break anyway did
did you did you cancel the van talk did
you did you cancel the bar that was not
me I was collateral damage that was the
cooler I mean no no that was I enjoyed
it and I'm sorry that I was the last
episode of barstool van talks did you
did you would you rather be the firt
would you rather been the first initial
guests to have aired at all the last one
rather been what you were yeah okay oh
yeah yeah yeah there will be a thirty
four thirty on barstool van talks coming
up Thank You reg thanks Rich Eisen for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]